[Music]
highlight is a dance this is a game of
finesse it's fast the ball go between
150 170 miles per hour for the better
part of the 20th century highlight was
the sport in my ear you want to see it
and to be seen yet today the sport is
barely a you know so what happened
[Music]
highlights a sport there was very famous
back in the 40s 50s and it's it comes
from Europe Spain France in 1924 it
arrived in Miami High Line one of the
oldest of all games is taking winter
residence at Miami by storm it's been
dubbed the world's fastest game you may
have vague memories of seeing it in a
DOS techies commercial or in the opening
scene of Miami Vice it was an exciting
sport and we used to get a lot of
celebrities that would come out and want
to be a part of it and want to be seen
at high Ally that's Benny boy no he's
one of the most decorated American
highlight players of all time he's
currently the player manager at Dania
casino it was a combination of the
nightlife and getting dressed up and
having a place to go the largest crowd
that ever visited Miami highlight was
15,000 people the arena held probably
about 12,000 it's just something that's
visually stimulating for someone that's
never seen it's addicting in a sense
I've been playing highlight for 28 years
I got to experience a good five years of
78,000 people and the fronton was so
loud you couldn't really hear your
partners and it was just awesome to play
in front of human bro now the inevitable
question how did we go from crowds of
ten thousand-plus to a scattered hundred
on a good day I believe it was in the
mid 30s that gambling was legalized on
highlight the wagering on highlight has
always been a blessing and a curse in
the sense where the wagering is what has
kept it alive for so long but it is kind
of taking away a little bit of the the
sport the athleticism the game itself
over the years the focus has changed
it's no longer a high Li arena it is a
casino with a high liar Rina with a
poker room and the focus is mainly on
the property rather than just the sport
of highlight but that wasn't a sports
only problem in 1981 then owner of world
high Roger wheeler was assassinated his
murder is associated with Whitey Bulger
and the Winter Hill Gang and the sport
became annexed early tied to organized
crime in the public's mind then in 1988
there was a player strike that lasted
three years
it all was the perfect storm where it
started to take some of our clientele
away I don't want it to be on my watch
that high Li goes away or fails it's a
lot of fun and it's something that I did
for 25 years so I can't just walk away
looking out at the crowd and seeing less
people doesn't deter my work ethic I'm
gonna play the same level and prepare
myself whether it's a thousand people or
200 people once the balls in the air you
got a move playing sport at that speed
every day you know it's awesome I still
have the love and the passion for the
game
[Music]
you